hot breath that's a great place to start
with this with
stay at home comedian your newest
special you just released
based off instagram live videos
could you i tried researching i always
researched my guests and i tried
researching into the origin story of
this but
i haven't found it so would you be able
to share that with us here
sure thing yeah so basically once the
pandemic hit and once the quarantine
specifically hit uh you know comedy
clubs were shut down
uh i had been touring with jim gaffigan
and we were actually just on our way
to mexico we were about i think you know
a few days away from
doing a week in mexico so
uh all of that was canceled we were
supposed to be at radio city
in in new york that was cancelled so all
of a sudden you know just
yeah just a minor gig you know nothing
big a bar
[Laughter]
so all of a sudden i'm looking at an
empty slate
so like a lot of comedians i kind of
turn to
alternate platforms so i have a podcast
so i started doing
two podcasts a week on my podcast is
called a little bit me and i also
started
um live streaming on instagram live it
just kind of
seemed like a natural fit like since i
wasn't able to get up on stages
and because all this weird stuff was
going on i felt like
you know let me try to process this in
real time and let me
also with instagram live uh much like
facebook
you're able to see comments in real time
so i kind of felt like it's a good
interactive thing as well um so then
over the course of a couple weeks
i just thought to myself you know if i
take the best moments
of these weeks of uh you know live
streams a lot of them were close to an
hour
in length you know just kind of take the
highlights and string them together
this could be uh something worth putting
out and then
the more i thought about it it would be
kind of funny almost like
tongue-in-cheek
to refer to it as a comedy special even
though it was shot in quarantine in my
apartment
uh so it's like almost like the
anti-special really because it's uh
as small and as intimate as can be